wenn nur wasser aus dem auspuff kommt
man weiß ist auch dass wenn ich alleine
fahre ich der einzige bin der co2
produziert und die ganze welt etwas
lernen kann und so wasserstoffproduktion
infos bilder ist eigentlich die
blaupause die sie überall auf der welt
aufbauen können und sie auch stolz auf
das sind was sie erreicht haben
sondern es ist schon
genial eigentlich dass wir das hier vor
ort produzieren und nutzen können dann
sind wir ganz oben im norden
deutschlands erstes modell projekt bei
dem eine region ohne fossile brennstoffe
auskommen will und voll auf wasserstoff
setzt doch die gut klappt das und wie
teuer ist das für die bewohner
[Musik]
seit einigen wochen fahren zwei busse
mit wasserstoff im linieneinsatz
für das projekt wurden mehrere
tankstellen gebaut an denen auch autos
wasserstoff tanken kann und wie findet
der fahrer den neuen bus
das futter in dem busses wasser
geräuschlos fährt hat man hört nur den
elektromotor und man hört nur das
lenkgetriebe ansonsten ist ruhe
wenn natürlich fahrgäste in bussen kann
man die gespräche mithören manchmal ist
es nicht so schön aber man hört denn
irgendwann nicht mehr hin und achtet
dann eben auf andere sachen im bus wie
zum beispiel den straßenverkehr doch ist
der bus auch alltagstauglich
aktuell ist das problem dass es manchmal
mit der tank und schwierig ist das heißt
dass der bus und die tankanlage nicht
miteinander sprechen das ist ein
softwareproblem das kann man lösen mit
ein paar software updates sollte das
gelöst sein das herzstück des
wasserstoff projekts das ist hier unser
elektrolyseur
wo sie eröffnen andré steiner hat das
modellprojekt ins leben gerufen seine
firma betreibt in elektrolyseur mehrere
millionen euro hat er gekostet
in dem container wird aus wasser der
begehrte wasserstoff gewonnen dafür wird
viel strom benötigt wir leben hier im
netz engpass gebiet das heißt windstrom
wird hier abgeschaltet das wären
überschussstrom und da war die idee was
fangen wir mit dem strom an wir wollen
wir nicht wegwerfen und die eine idee
ist in dieser stromüberschuss zeit
diesen strom zwischen zu speichern und
dann zu nutzen wenn er nicht wenn die
erneuerbare energien nicht direkt
vorhanden ist und darüber hinaus deren
anwendung zu finden dass wir die energie
nicht nur wieder ans stromnetz
zurückgeben sondern in die anderen
sektoren wie mobilität und auch wärme
und so wird's gemacht mit hilfe des
windstroms wird wasserstoff aus
gerichten leitungswasser abgespaltet der
wird dann zu den örtlichen
wasserstofftankstellen transportiert
bei der wasserstoff gewinnung entsteht
viel wärme diese wird ins örtliche
fernwärmenetz geleitet so werden häuser
co2 neutral beheizt und zwar die im nahe
gelegenen dorf buschkühl
max böhm profitiert davon bislang gebe
es keine probleme damit meint der
handwerker die werbe ist jetzt ein
anfang mit dem gesamtprojekt natürlich
auch in bezug auf die busse auf den
anfang schön wäre es natürlich wenn auch
hier einfach ein oder zwei wasserstoff
autos vor der tür stehen das ist
momentan weiß ich noch nicht so so dass
sich jeder leisten kann oder dass auch
wir uns leisten können aber ich kann mir
gut vorstellen das ist das schon zu
definitiv ein wasserstoffauto kostet
ungefähr doppelt so viel wie ein
vergleichbares dieselmodell deshalb
fahren erst 30 stück in der region
auch das tanken ist teurer für 500 km
sind 50 euro fällig
während es beim diesel 47 sind und beim
elektroauto 25 euro
also wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen dass
eine klimaschutz orientierte wirtschaft
teurer ist als eine fossil orientierte
wirtschaft das heißt klimaschutz und da
sind wir ja alle daran interessiert dass
wir unsere welt retten und wir sind
jetzt am anfang einer technologie die
die schon lange gibt aber dies halt noch
nicht in massen einsatz in der form gab
und gibt und die durch den masseneinsatz
aber auch günstiger wird schon in
wenigen jahren könnte die
klimafreundliche energien und genau so
teuer sein wie die herkömmliche so
glauben sie hier die beispiele zeigen
dass die angewandte technik bereits
alltagstauglich ist
[Musik]